[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to your first look at the
samsung galaxy s10 e
oh we don't know what the e stands for
yet so i'm just gonna go with economy so
there is a video up already at the same
exact time on the new galaxy s10 and s10
plus the flagships of the lineup so the
link's here to watch it or it'll be the
first link below but this s10e is a new
addition to the lineup coming in at a
bit of a lower price kind of just like
what apple did in september with their
iphones some people thought apple's
getting a little loose releasing a third
phone alongside the other two that may
get a little confusing but then again
samsung already makes like 10 000 phones
so i guess we shouldn't be surprised by
this duplication of strategy so if the
galaxy s10 and s10 plus are perfect
matches alongside the iphone 10s and 10s
max which they kind of are then this
galaxy s10e is a perfect parallel to the
iphone 10r and that's starting with the
price it is 750 bucks just like the 10r
which is definitely again not budget by
any means but it is lower than the other
flagship phones it's launching with so
with that where are you saving your
money well the form factor of the s10e
is super similar to the regular s10 as
you can see but it cuts some corners
literally to save price and that starts
with the display which is a bit smaller
now it's a 5.8 inch amoled display and
it's flat now instead of curved so
basically the infinity display on the
higher end phones sort of melts
gloriously over the sides the s10e has a
flat screen meaning it goes mostly edge
to edge but it's a little less dramatic
matter of fact it's similar to the
iphone 10r in that the bezels all the
way around are just a little bit thicker
just a slightly taller chin
slightly cut inside bezels it's not
problematic at all in fact i think most
people would hardly notice but it's just
people like me who are pixel peeping
that are gonna see that but it's still
an over 90 screen to body ratio and also
just so i don't forget to say it the
display on this s10e while it is
slightly lesser than the two higher end
brothers it's still way better than the
display apple put in the iphone 10r this
was an lcd this was a much lower
resolution the display on the s10e is
still a 500 plus pixel per inch amoled
display so it's got the same
characteristics the same hole punch but
it's just a slightly lesser than the
older brothers anyway another one of the
big new features of the s10 was of
course the ultrasonic fingerprint reader
underneath the display glass that's
pretty high-end expensive tech s10e
doesn't have that instead it actually
uses a traditional fingerprint reader
and it's in the power button on the
right hand side this is probably the
best backup location to put it in i
usually prefer on the back of phones
just because that's where my finger
naturally rests but uh the power button
is also great because you're often
pressing that button anyway and your
finger usually rests there too so then
the last major trade-off of the galaxy
s10e is just like the iphone 10r
removing one of the cameras so the
bigger brother has an extra camera the
galaxy s10 just got triple cameras which
means the galaxy s10e now has dual
cameras so it shares the same high-end
dual aperture primary camera and it also
keeps the ultra wide so it doesn't have
the telephoto camera anymore which i
think is great because most people
rarely intentionally use the telephoto
camera anyway and then on paper with the
specs they even did what apple did with
the soc and the ram iphone 10r had the
same chip but a little bit less ram so
here comes galaxy s10e it has also the
same snapdragon 855 like its brothers
but it starts with six gigs of ram
instead of eight but again you can
upgrade to get a version with more ram
and more storage if you want to spend a
little bit more but also to be honest
most people buying phones like this
probably won't notice the difference
between six and eight gigs of ram anyway
that's more about future proofing and
overhead and to be fair we'll see how
these phones perform down the line after
the reviews this phone also has ip68
certification this phone also has
expandable storage it's not missing
those things but also note because the
phone's a little bit smaller the battery
is also a bit smaller so it's a 3 100
milliamp hour battery in the s10e which
is still bigger than the battery of last
year's galaxy s9 so overall galaxy s10e
appears to be a pretty great phone that
costs just a bit less than samsung's
other new phones the sacrifices come in
the three main areas of display
fingerprint and cameras but they're
still pretty good at all those areas so
similar to the iphone 10 our first
impression it feels like this is gonna
be the phone of the new ones that most
people should get to save that 150 bucks
but you can let me know what you think
would you spend the extra money on the
super fancy display and the fingerprint
reader and the extra camera or would you
save that money let me know either way
stay tuned for the full review of this
phone thanks for watching the first
impressions and hands-on feel free to
share it with others who may be
interested talk to you guys in the next
one
peace